or definitely gonna be spending our
evenings picking salmon berries which is
when the salmon are here after July then
the salmon berry should be raped while
chip collects building supplies for
their fish rack and sig woke Magnus and
the girls must gather and stockpile a
vital food source for the coming winter
it takes a group effort
to get through these Willows cuz you
never know what's in the Willows there
could be bears wolves musk ox that's why
we have the puppy dog here so it can
just scare off anything look at the size
of these berries right I usually just
try to keep picking all the ones that
are orange you can tell how good and
nice they are and I just try to leave
the ones that are already sunburnt and
stuff and not great when we have our
long cold winter it's nice to have
something sweet besides all the meats
and fish we have so we balance it out
with the berries and the greens not
missing anything from our diet it's hard
work it's back-breaking but in the end
it pays off
whoo that looks like that's enough for
today we could just pack up and start
heading back
these short pieces right here are
cottonwoods those are gonna be for smoke
good salmon then I got these pine ones
over here and we're gonna be using those
for making the signal
stick your guys's berries in it's all
the barriers you got don't have to be
eaten right away we can save them for
winter it's like a good deal I make a
real good deal yep no work out good dope
yeah we all work out real good together
this one gets a little mini